we did it this city means the world to
me tampa forever
all right only 30 more teams to go gronk
we're out bug ground just bought a house
just buy another
look at this guy a super bowl winning
quarterback me i lost a super bowl and
two years later they shipped me off to
detroit with this guy
whoa welcome to the lion king have
dinner or become dinner they traded
stafford to la oh god the sun for me
a third and two first oh got a tip
here's a 2024 first round pick suddenly
the price for a qba increased even more
which gave one man
an idea jason we're gonna drive up the
price of quarterback stock
[Music]
hello media can i interest you in taste
some hill
he's mormon but also old well gosh i
don't know jason could pot and return
the same kick well all right tasting to
the moon baby lock me in i got you no
cap
confusing here's adam left going to
bathtub to explain the saints are 100
million dollars over the salary cap
already and this year the cap
is actually going to get lower for the
first time in a decade so the saints
need to increase taysom's trade value
you guys are gonna make me look good
right so taysom is now worth 40 million
a year
so is the exit interview over they are
making more money than me we need to
impose restrictions maybe jason is good
no
everything is about great season team
state farm
yeah hope for safe farm
[Music]
money ever died so with taste of rising
the price on more
experienced cubies went through the roof
dang it
i gotta sell my jumbo trying to buy you
this is why you should have extended me
earlier
gerald used cars selling a lightly used
car man
this baby still drives man look the
internet says now i'm worth half a
donald coin
jason watch me dance uh coach you should
trade hold the line
sorry deshawn if taysom hill is now
worth 10 first no one on planet earth
can afford you
i appreciate your time and just like
that the qb market crashed overnight
which
produced pure chaos no team is better
than some teams
protect me uh hurts or wins or wins or
hurts or or what wins it's gonna be good
to get back
man i hate this [ __ ] sport i need to
figure out a way to cover this up did
somebody say
cover-up bourbon meyer introducing young
kids you don't have to pay
you know you need to pay us now whoa
what
[Music]
thank you all so much for watching this
season it's a real shame in her stand
you know what i'm not leaving i'm not
leaving
the show goes on clammy no the season
actually is over they can
a silent sweet as long as you won't buy
delaware clam shirts in the police
report store
all right the clam is belligerent send
in teami sure should be about gaming
come on